What are we doing here, man?
>> It's God. It's God. It's God.
It's God.
>> What's going on everybody? Welcome to
God Logic Apologetics. I'm here with
Lady Logic herself. Man, she had an
opportunity to hop on a panel with three
other amazing Christian sisters, Tai
Chanasa, and
>> Kalia.
>> Kalia. And they went to work. They sat
across from four other Muslims. They had
a conversation. Now,
>> my beautiful wife.
>> Yes.
>> This was your first time getting out
there in the public. Tell us uh tell us
how that felt. Man,
>> I was really nervous and I don't know
why. I don't know why. cuz once the
conversation got flowing, I was like,
"Oh, this is just a talk. We're just
talking."
>> But um you know, being Lady Logic, being
God Logic's wife
>> is um it's tough. I mean, it's a
wonderful thing, but there is that
pressure of hey, I got to do well. I've
got to represent. I can't get cooked out
here.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You better get cooked. I had
to make sure that I knew my stuff, that
I was ready, and I wanted to come across
as loving, but also firm. And so, I'm
really hoping that that that's what I
did.
>> Yeah, you did a good job. You and the
other ladies, y'all did a good job of
having that balance of, you know, grace
and love and firmness. Like you guys
were unapologetic about the gospel,
about the truth, about you guys not
serving the same God as you know as the
Muslims. Like the God of the Bible is a
different God than what is described in
the Quran. You guys were very clear on
that. Didn't leave no questions about
that. So,
>> absolutely. When I got there to the
studio and we saw that it was Trinasa
and Kalia from the previous episode,
>> oh yeah,
>> I was like, "Wow, these are some
beasts." like they were my favorite from
the previous video
>> and I just absolutely loved them. And
when we got on that stage together,
>> it was like we'd known each other for
years. We just flowed. We were having
each other's back, playing off of each
other. It was just completely natural.
And they made me feel so at ease. And of
course, my girl Ty, who I already know
um and love dearly. It was just we're
quite the squad. I really enjoyed being
with them.
>> That panel was stacked, man. That panel
was stacked. And we're going to see what
uh what the comment section thought
about uh such a panel when we get into
this cuz that is awesome. Now, so uh one
of the prompts was about hell and
whether or not uh you you can go to
heaven if you are a disbeliever in said
religion. And so let's take a look and
see how this went here. In Sahi Muslim
2662,
Aisha is at the funeral of a young boy
and it says that he's too young to have
committed sin. So she's like telling
Muhammad surely he's in paradise because
he's too young to have committed a sin.
And Muhammad says per adventure it may
be otherwise.
So I'm just curious in light of this
idea that you know children are not
guilty of sin. Why would it be otherwise
that he would be in paradise?
>> So the hadith that's mentioned in the uh
you said
>> Muslim
>> hadith is the prophet's narrations and
um
>> first of all off the dome knowing having
that hadith ready not just the contents
of the hadith but sah Muslim 2662.
Okay, that's the one that was uh Yeah,
you're dangerous. I try to not bring it
if I don't remember where it's at
because of answers like what I'm going
to get from this lady.
>> Yeah. Let's see.
>> So the word hadith means the we have to
make sure before we discuss that how
solid is this hadith because lot of
hadith were input in lot of big books.
So it you know we have to investigate
and see if it is the right hadith and it
will have an explanation to support what
comes in the Quran. So all the prophetic
hadith they the original ones they
support what comes in the Quran. It
can't be contradictory
>> right? So this one is considered to be
sah which means authentic right? No, it
depends. It depends. We can't assume
that. But like I said, if there's a
clear verse in the Quran that a human
being are born without sin,
>> the hadith that are supportive of that,
they are the right. Otherwise, correct
me if I'm wrong.
>> The word sahi,
>> yeah,
>> it means authentic.
>> Well, it depends on um how you feel in
that moment.
>> Oh, how you feel in the moment.
>> Yes, it it depends on how you feel. Uh
if you're talking about like literally
if you're just reading it and just
knowing just the word itself. Yeah, sahi
means authentic. It's good. Uh better
than good. It's it's it's authentic.
It's sound.
>> So you can't really question sound
hadith. Especially if you're a Sunni
Muslim like the sister is here.
>> Yeah. So but that's your fault for
assuming
>> that sahi Muslim was authentic. Mhm.
>> And it was also my fault for assuming
that if we brought it up, we could
actually talk about it.
>> Yeah.
>> Versus disputing over whether or not
it's uh
>> Well, you're not a scholar,
>> right? So why would I be able to discuss
something I read?
>> Exactly.
>> That children aren't guilty of sin. My
question is like we're like Aisha,
right? We're like why, you know, this
kid is too young to have committed sin.
So I don't think that Quran verse you're
mentioning contradicts that idea. But
more so my question is if children are
innocent then why would the possibility
of the child not being in paradise be a
thing?
>> Like I said again the the hadith does
not if it does not align with the Quran
then we have to assume that it's not a
concrete solid hadith. There were a lot
of hadith input in even big books famous
books.
>> So I mean the hadith collection is full
of big books huge books guys. uh and you
know you you got to really search
through them and really uh seek
scholarship and making sure it's sound.
You did she she didn't touch the
contents of that hadith. A matter of
fact, actually she kind of alluded it to
being contradictory to what the Quran
teaches.
>> Right? And so tell me this watching that
was my question clear?
>> Your question was very clear. So
>> okay, because this is what I was trying
to express your idea that children are
innocent. I completely agree with why
are innocent children going to hell?
>> Exactly.
>> So I'm not talking about whether or not
they're innocent. I'm talking about
whether or not they get punished. And
she brings up a Quran verse where
children are innocent. Well, that's not
what
>> she didn't even bring up a Quran verse.
>> She sure didn't.
>> She didn't bring up a She made a claim.
>> She made a claim.
>> She made a claim um and said that this
seems to contradict. If it contradicts
the the Quran, then we can't accept it.
It's it's it's false. It's a fake hadith
or whatever. It's fabricated. She didn't
bring a verse. She didn't quote a single
I would have loved to have been like,
"Okay, let's hear a verse." But not a
single verse was brought. Your question
was very clear. You brought a reference.
You quoted the reference word for word
and uh
>> from the mouth of Aisha herself.
>> Look, we we're we're the Aisha crew,
>> right?
Yeah, you made a good point. We're like
Aisha. We think that the child who dies,
especially before puberty, before they
can even commit sin, that they're going
to go straight to paradise. No question.
But Muhammad says, "Hold on a second.
Hold your horses. It may be otherwise
because Allah created for hell those who
are to go to hell." and before they were
in their father's loins and vice versa
for paradise. Why is that a possibility
for an innocent child who couldn't have
committed sin if according to your
religion kids are all innocent straight
to paradise? You know,
>> you know, uh there were a couple of
places I wanted to potentially go here
in this topic, but I learned quickly
because this was the first prompt. I
learned quickly that you kind of get a
few minutes to talk about it and then
you have to move on. But I definitely
wanted to try to go to predestination in
Islam. I wanted to go to other hadith
that mention um children going to hell.
So there was a lot I wanted to be able
to go to, but you move really quick on
this show.
>> Yeah, for sure. But that was a good
little exchange there. So we got a uh
other little parts that stood out to me
that I want us to touch on. I want to
get your inner monologue when we talk
about this. Now, um, this is like
touching on the subject of whether or
not you can be a believer and go to hell
or uh, uh, a disbeliever and go to
heaven in Islam. And this is how this
sister responded
>> if we don't follow your particular
religion or faith that we would go to
hell. So from my upbringing and my
understanding of the Quran, no. There's
a verse in chapter 2 62 that says,
"Christians, Jews, believers, anyone who
believes in God, believes in the day of
judgment and does good on earth has no
fear and God will reward them in the
hereafter."
>> So according to this Muslima, if you are
a disbeliever, it doesn't matter. It's
okay. You will still go to paradise. As
a matter of fact, she doubled down on
this a little bit later. Um, and here's
your response.
>> 262,
it's talking about converts. I think
it's very clear because like we spoke of
earlier, you have to believe in Allah in
the last day. And how do you reconcile
that with verses like 385 where it says
those who seek another religion other
than Islam will not be accepted
and there will be losers in the
hereafter.
>> What was that? Why you chuckle when you
said there will be losers?
>> Be losers.
after that. I don't know something about
that verse, you're going to be a loser.
>> That just really cracked me up. But I am
so glad cuz if you go back and you watch
this full thing, um the conversation got
diverted when she first brought it up
and I was like, I want to talk about
this
>> and being able to bring it back up made
me so happy cuz I wanted to challenge
that. Um
>> and that's the thing, all of these
ladies were absolutely lovely. They were
sweethearts. I mean, after this, we all
hugged, but
there were several moments where I just
feel like either intentionally or
unintentionally,
>> they're lying.
>> There was dishonesty.
>> Yeah,
>> straight up lying. I'll say it.
>> There's moments where where some of them
are just probably just straight up
lying. Uh, but hey, you know, or maybe
they genuinely think this and they're
lost and
>> if I'm being
>> charitable,
>> if I'm being charitable, I do think that
she genuinely believes this. But
>> again, she never answers my question,
how do you reconcile your belief based
on that one verse
>> with this verse?
>> But let's see your let's see how this
this engagement goes. Those who seek
another religion other than Islam will
not be accepted
and they will be losers in the
hereafter.
>> Repeated verses where God says like we
will call them according to their books.
As long as you believe in God, you
believe in the day of judgment and you
do good, you have to be a good person.
Which is kind of going back to what we
were saying earlier about why we strive
and why we do our practices to support
our conviction of the hereafter. We h
we're driven by the good deeds because
that is a tenant of our faith. So Da, do
you believe Christians will go to
heaven?
>> I do.
>> Right there. So, so even the Muslim
sister next to her had to be like, you
know, okay. So, do you believe you
believe that Christians will go to
heaven? She says, "I do." And she just,
"Okay." You know, she doesn't correct
her. Even though I like with that, I I
knew that she didn't agree with that.
She doesn't agree with that.
>> She absolutely didn't agree with her.
And here's the thing. Um,
that's what makes having these
conversations like this a little bit
difficult because you will have Muslims
who will say something eumenical or
something um, patable to
>> make Islam appealing.
>> Yeah.
>> And then when you open the book and it
says the exact opposite thing of what
you just said, I'm asking you, how do
you have this opinion when Allah says
otherwise?
>> Yep. They don't like Allah's words, man.
And this is typical. you you they do not
like what Allah says.
>> That's why if I come across like I'm
trying to press them, it's only when I
feel like they're being dishonest.
>> That's all. I mean, what what are you
going to do? Just sit there and just let
let the lie go? No. No.
>> Even earlier when we were talking about
the hadith, had she not said, "Oh, it's
not authentic." Even though it's sahi
Muslim, if she had said, "You know what?
Yeah, it's Allah's decision to send
children if to hell if he wants to, and
um he's God and that's his right." You
know what I would have said? Halas.
Colossal.
Sure.
>> Okay. I I can respect that because you
are honoring what your book says and
you're saying he's God and if that's
what he wants to do, that's what it is.
>> Can't fault you.
>> So, there was another segment where you
guys were talking about the deity of
Christ. um the claims that Jesus makes.
>> And I really love this part because you
got you got them to say something and
admit something that uh I just knew
other Muslims would hate. I I just I I
as a me putting myself in a Muslim shoes
watching this, I I probably would have
turned this off like after listening to
this.
>> Um so they try to you know, we'll just
we'll just let y'all look at this. Let's
let's watch this part here.
Jesus says that um I um I do not do
anything by myself. I do it by the will
of God. So uh that particular statement
that's actually exactly what a Muslim
says. I don't do anything by my own
will. I submit to the will of God. That
is the definition of a
>> also a verse in the Quran about what
Jesus said. I can't do any of this
without the will of God.
>> Except no Muslim
>> exactly match.
>> No Muslim would say that everything that
God does they can do. that they do
everything they see the father doing. So
when you finish that verse right there,
Jesus is making a divine claim. He says,
"I do nothing without the father.
Everything the father does, I do. For
the father shows me all that he does."
So is that Islamic to believe that a
creature can do everything that the
father can do
>> from a mystical point of view? Yes.
What?
What? Such a a a straightforward
surgical question. Simple. And this is
what these type of things do for the
Muslim. It's either that you you're put
in a in a predicament. Either I be
honest and say no, no prophet can say
this and then therefore I have to
acknowledge that Jesus is claiming to be
God even in the Bible. Or two, I can be
dishonest and say something completely
radical, say something completely off
base, and now I have to defend this
crazy position. So now she's not
appealing to Islam. Really? She's
appealing to mysticism. Now, guys, wow.
What were you what were you thinking in
that moment when she said, "Oh yeah, if
you uh if you go to mysticism." Yeah.
>> I was 100% expecting to get a no to my
question. The whole reason for my
question was for it to be
thoughtprovoking. Obviously, you cannot
say this. So, yes, let's acknowledge
that Jesus is saying something more than
a creature could say. And I thought that
was going to be the end of it.
>> It should have been.
>> It should have been. And never in my
wildest dreams did I think I was going
to get the answer that I did get, which
is what makes conversations like this so
much fun.
>> But
>> I think she did Islam a disservice here.
That's not the orthodox belief. Why are
you bringing this?
>> Yeah. Why you why you appealing to this,
man?
>> Would you say that? Do you believe that?
>> Wait, let's let's let's see how how you
handle this. You know, like we got to
check your reaction here. Praise God.
Hallelujah.
>> But no matter how much we love God,
wouldn't we want to be careful with what
we say? Because there is a separate a
distinction between us and God. We're
created. He's not. I just think that
goes kind of against I don't know if any
of you ladies would say that the way
that he said that even though you love
God, right?
>> Yeah. Would you say I am a law in the
same way that
>> with the assist?
>> Hold on. Listen.
>> Yeah. Would you say I am Allah in the
same way that
>> he was on a different path? He's a
>> He was on a different path. So why bring
him up? Why bring this heretical Sufi
Muslim up if he's on a different path
and is nothing that you would follow or
or mimic in regards to your dean and
your religion that this is not the right
way to follow. He was on a different
path. He wasn't on the straight path.
Why are you bringing him up then?
>> Allah is on the straight path.
>> Allah's Okay, you know, he might may be
talking about Allah here, man.
>> Um,
>> so good. That was so good.
>> Yeah.
>> Speaking of, man, uh, you really wasn't
holding back. you went straight for it,
especially when it came to the Quran
being the final revelation in
continuation with the other revelation.
And I just
I just loved your answer there.
>> Gee, I wonder why.
>> I just I I was just cheesing from ear to
ear at this part. Just for context here,
they're talking about the Quran
correcting the Bible, correcting the
previous scriptures. Yes. And so you
give a beautiful response here.
>> That's an interesting answer. And I get
that answer often when I'm speaking with
Muslims about whether or not the Quran
confirms or corrects the previous
scripture. But when I actually read the
Quran, it says the exact opposite of the
answers that I get from ladies such as
yourself. I mean 1094
Muhammad. If you are in doubt about what
Allah has revealed to you, what did
Allah revealed to Muhammad? The Quran.
If you're in doubt about what Allah has
revealed, go and ask the people who have
been reading the scripture before you.
>> Talk lady logic.
>> If you doubt the Quran, you're supposed
to go and check the previous script
scripture according to Allah. Mhm.
>> You have 381 where
>> Allah is telling the prophets that
there's a messenger coming after them
that's going to confirm all that Allah
has given them of the scripture and of
the hikma.
>> You like that?
>> You have over and over again. I mean,
there's verse after verse, chapter 2,
chapter 5, full of verses about how
Muhammad and Muslims are supposed to go
back to the previous scripture because
the Quran is supposed to come in line
with it confirming what was before, not
contradicting it. So then when we see
that the Quran contradicts the previous
scripture, the answer that I get is
that, oh well, it came to correct it.
Nowhere in the Quran or Hadith is the
Quran a correction over the previous
scripture. In fact, it's the other way
around. But let's talk about one
example.
>> Watch her do
>> for example,
>> watch her do exactly what I just said.
>> Yeah. So, the opposite of what the Quran
says and usually the answers that you
get. Yep.
>> So, Allah says, "Hey guys, use the
previous scriptures to check the Quran
to make sure the Quran is correct."
uh she's going to bring up an example
where she thinks and is going to make
the claim that the Quran is actually
correcting the Torah, correcting the
Bible. Um it's tough. She brings up Lot,
but let's hear this.
>> Yeah.
>> The story of Lot in uh in the Bible,
when you read the story of Lot, it says
that um Lot's daughters got him drunk
and then uh slept with him. the uh this
story when you read the same story in
the in the Quran, it's a completely
different story, it doesn't say anything
about the daughters getting their father
drunk. And
>> you see my face.
>> She literally did exactly what I just
said she was going to do.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, verbatim, she comes up with a
story in the Quran that doesn't match
the Bible and says that it's a
correction.
>> That's exactly what goes against what
the Quran says. And that's why in that
clip, the expression on my face, I'm
trying to contain my laughter cuz I was
thinking in my head, you can't make this
up. You can't make this up.
>> Can't make this up, man. What What What
we What we doing here, man?
>> What in the world we doing here, dog?
>> Oh, that's good. This was a This was
excellent. Uh, I want to get into the
comment section here because the Muslims
in the comments were going crazy. They I
mean
>> it it was gold in there. It was it was
just gold. So let's get into these
comments section. Let's see what we got
pulling up. All right. So here's a
comment from Suso who says, "Woman, are
you kidding me? Every Muslim knows Sah
Bkari and Sahi Muslim are the two most
authentic Hadith narrators after the
Quran."
To answer the girl's question, a simple
research explained to me that the
prophet is teaching us to not judge
someone too quickly because only God
knows what lies ahead for them. You
should not have said the hadith
contradicts the Quran or questions the
hadith's authenticity because Bkari and
Muslim only and exclusively have 100%
authentic hadith. No place for doubt.
And that's a Muslim, right?
>> That's a m This is a mumon right here,
man. All these these comments are going
to be from the Muslims. We're reading
all the Muslims. This is from Raj A1 who
says, "I would really want to know where
you brought these Muslims from. They did
such a bad job and painted a bad image
about us." Tough.
>> If he's so brave and he thinks he would
do a better job, he can come on up on
your channel. Hey man, Monday,
Wednesday, Friday, 5:00 p. p.m. Eastern
Standard Time. Uh, God Logic Apologetics
channel. We live every time, man. You
can come on through.
>> Yep. If you're a man and you think or a
woman and you think you can do better
than what those Muslim ladies did,
>> come on through. Come on through.
>> And you better not have the same answer.
>> Alhamdulillah Yeshua. All right, we got
a comment from uh Dio who says, "These
Muslim sisters need to go back and learn
their dean. This is so embarrassing to
watch as a Muslim. They clearly do not
know their dean. Kept making so many
basic blunders. Couldn't reference even
a single very clear verse out of many in
the Quran that would strongly support
their positions. Dear Muslim women,
please learn your dean. This would have
been a cakewalk for any Muslim with a
basic understanding of Islam that is
rooted in reading and understanding the
Quran. Alhamdulillah, we have so many
great da'ah channels these days. It is
not hard to answer any of these
questions and to defend the Islamic
point of view. This was a difficult
watch as a Muslim. Respect to the
Christian ladies for understanding their
faith and for fiercely defending it.
They did very well. Wow.
>> Wow.
>> I like him, man. We got Wahed Khan. He
says, "Sorry, but you need to bring
people who have the knowledge and can
debate. This is the second time where
the women don't have enough knowledge,
especially from the Muslim side, making
Muslims look dumb. This seems quite
calculated and it makes an unfair
representation. The Muslim women came
across as though they had zero
understanding of their religion and just
stayed quiet.
>> If I'm not mistaken, two of the women
that we spoke with had PhDs and one was
a Quran teacher.
>> Yeah. Paradise said. Go ahead and read
that for him, babe.
Sorry, but they said a lot of falsehood.
So, the confusion of the Christians is
very understandable. Wow, they made some
good points. We do not believe
Christians of today enter paradise. And
yes, we do believe they commit sherk
through the trinity. There are specific
verses about how disturbing the belief
of the trinity is in the Quran. Anyways,
one who commits sherk, we do not view
them as believers and only believers
enter paradise. As for the Christians
and Jews of before, of course they will
be because we believe they followed the
truth back then before it was changed.
So they did not take a man as God.
>> Oh, nice. Nice. Okay, so man, we got a
they a lot of criticism against the
Muslim ladies. Let's see what else we
got here, man.
Go ahead, read this one.
>> This is so sad. This channel is so
biased and whoever runs this is so
insecure about their faith that every
time they pick Muslims that are in no
way educated enough about both
scriptures to debate. Seriously, that
one lady cannot even say the Arabic word
from the Quran. This is crazy. It's so
hard for me to believe that someone
chosen to debate for Islam does not know
the basics. I completely understand for
regular Muslims and even rebirths can't
quickly learn Arabic in order to read
the Quran in its original language. Some
never do and that's fine. Allah
encouraged effort not perfection. But
for someone to debate for a whole
religion, they better have deep
knowledge of both the Quran and the many
Bibles. M
>> I dare this channel to level the playing
field and to be fair, let the audience
decide instead of trying to manipulate
us and pushing your agenda.
>> I think that the audience did decide. I
mean, when you're reading not the
Christian comments, when you're reading
the Muslim comments, the Christian
ladies definitely dominated the
discussion. And we're not talking about
in rhetoric. we're talking about in
knowledge, in in responses, in
thoughtful answers, uh, in engagement.
The Christian side was so much more
prepared than the Muslim side. And
here's why. Because Islam is
indefensible. You cannot defend Islam.
You you the only thing you can do is
misrepresent what the Quran says and
then also misrepresent what the Bible
says. That's all we're going to see. So
unfortunately, it doesn't matter how
many times you do this. Each group of
Muslims is going to fail because they're
defending a false religion.
>> I listen to my husband talk to Muslims
every single day. The ladies on stage
outside of a few outlers
give the exact same answers that every
other Muslim guy does every single day
on God Logic Apologetics. Sophia says,
"I hope this is a lesson to our sisters
that even if you compromise your
religion in order to be liked by the
disbelievers." Wow. They are still going
to hate you. It is clear to see who just
wants to have a nice discussion and who
wants to fight. You should call the show
I'm going let you read that. What should
they call the show?
>> You should call the show Muslim
Housewife Against Christian Apologists.
Wow.
>> We got one from Lea.
It sounds like it might be a female.
Says, "This was literally planned. They
don't even discuss the Christians. They
don't even discuss. The Christians are
just attacking the Muslims. I wish they
would talk to me. Do it to me then
later.
>> We definitely would love to talk to
you."
>> Monday, Wednesday, Friday.
>> Monday, Wednesday.
>> 5:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time. You can
come live. We could discuss. We could
bring up Lady Logic. could bring up the
other sisters. And if you are a Muslim
and you want to get into these
discussions, you think that they didn't
do that well and represent your
religion, you think you could do it
better, come on the live stream,
thousands of people will see it and you
will be able to represent your religion
the way it's supposed to be represented.
Natic says, "So, a Christian channel
decided to bring in uneducated Muslim
women to speak with educated Christian
women. And we also have God Logic,
a known Islam hate preacher." That's
what I'm known for, guys.
>> You give me too much credit.
>> In the comments, jumping in excitement.
You could give me all the money in the
world, I would never pretend this was
not a setup.
>> I feel so bad for my Christian brothers
and sisters that fall for this
propaganda. I feel worse for the Muslims
that have been physically harmed because
>> physically harmed
>> because of this kind of stuff.
>> Always want to be a victim. The moment I
saw that the host was a black Christian
woman just like all the other
Christians, my gut instantly told me
this was not a fair video because y'all
was black.
>> So because we're black, your gut
instantly told, "Bro, you're racist,
bro."
>> Say sound like a little bit of to me.
>> A little racist, bro. You sounded like
your prophet a little bit, bro.
>> Sound a little bit like Muhammad there,
man. Top one. Go ahead and read that.
Christians will do anything just to win.
Clearly, those Muslims didn't know much
about the Bible and spent too much time
reacting instead of leading the
discussion. The channel obviously knows
which Christians are well-versed in
Islam. Thank you.
>> And picks them carefully to make strong
counterarguments against Muslims. That's
pure bad faith. They even take the wife
of God Logic who knows a lot about
Islam.
>> Christians really got to do everything
to win.
>> Wow. They even had Gal Logic's wife on
there, man. Why they cheating?
>> You know what that everything they got
to do to win,
>> man? Anything they got to do, man.
>> You know what that everything is?
>> What that what that everything is, man?
>> Read.
The only thing we do to win is just
read.
>> All I did was read.
>> We just read. They gave us the prompts.
They gave everyone the prompts a couple
of days in advance and that gave us time
to prepare. So you read and then you
remember what you read and you ask the
question when you get to the discussion
and that's all we did.
>> So with that being said, you guys, you
guys can check out the entire
discussion. The videos on doc the Dr.
Dav show on YouTube. Make sure you guys
go ahead and subscribe to her channel.
She's doing an amazing job, amazing
work, bringing in amazing conversations,
her and her husband. And so, uh,
>> very fair, very unbiased. They seek out
educated women on both sides of every
discussion that they bring.
>> Yep. So, go ahead, check out the full
video, Christian uh women versus Muslim
women. It just dropped a few days ago.
And uh make sure you guys hit the like
button, subscribe, tell us in this
comment section what you what you think
your favorite part of the discussion
was, points that you probably would have
brought up. If you're a Muslim, if you
think you can do better, let us know in
the comments section or come join a live
stream Monday, Wednesday, and Friday.
All right, and with that being said, we
just got one question for y'all, man.
What's the idea?
Oh my god. Logic.
[Music]